hey then you know what I realized when I
tried to buy a sandwich yesterday you
don't like sandwiches know that I have
no money mom eats it yes but it doesn't
mean that we can't play video games
that's true today's episode is themed
all around free video game things that
you can get so look at it with first up
take yourself over to the humble store
where you can grab Psychonauts on PC for
free the humble store which often has a
bunch of good deals is giving away the
classic Double Fine action-adventure for
none of your monies if you're wondering
what the catch is there you only have
until 10:00 a.m. Pt this Saturday to
claim it so act fast Double Fine fans if
you're looking for something a touch
krysya a free weekend has just kicked
off for the division on PEI state which
you can play up until September 17th if
you're a big fan you can also pick it up
on the cheap as part of the same
promotion for 20 bucks the free weekend
gives you access to the entirety of the
bass game but not these expansions
holy mackerel the deals don't stop there
overwatch is having a free weekend next
weekend yes if you're not already
playing it I think most people I don't
know but if you're not this one's for
you get involved you can play the
colorful hero shooter for free on PC ps4
and Xbox one beginning Friday September
22nd at 11 a.m. Pt until September 25th
at 11:59 p.m. Pt should you update
you'll have access to all of the games
25 heroes and 16 maps in a variety of
modes including quick play custom games
and the arcade you'll also be able to
earn loot boxes level up and unlock
cosmetics and if you do want to buy the
game after the trial all your progress
will carry over ps4 owners will need to
have a PlayStation Plus subscription in
order to take part while Xbox one owners
will need an Xbox Live Gold subscription
if you're on PC you can sign up for a
free battlenet account to participate if
you don't have one already all right so
this last one does involve you earning
the base game first but still free stuff
the premiere rocket-powered car soccer
game rocket league is getting its autumn
update very soon the update that adds
new items
player banners and a new seasonal arena
will arrive in two weeks on September
28th the new arena is called the
farmstead and well it's exactly as it
says on the tin it's set in the middle
of a farm you'll only be able to plant
soccer balls with your bumper / fender
at the farm stead for a limited time
this fall / autumn the update will also
introduce standard versions of the
wasteland and Starbase R arenas when the
update drops you'll have the
to snag 93 customization options which
will come in uncommon rare and very rare
flavors
after online matches finally the PC
version is getting land support as part
of the update and there will be new
limited time events and transparent goal
posts rocket League is available on ps4
Xbox one and PC and is coming to switch
this holiday with exclusive cars based
on Mario and Metroid that is everything
we've got for you today do let us know
your thoughts and feelings on today's
stories down in that comment section and
remember tomorrow is our top 5 of the
entire week so if you missed out on any
of the gaming news you can come back
then what do we got from day one of our
colleagues had a chat to quickly be
about lawbreakers this week and what
he's learned from the launch of his game
and we're gonna be talking about that
which I'm really excited about so you
should tune in and check that out hope
to see that three weekends 2017 is demos
holy mackerel the deals don't stop there
overwatch is also having a free weekend
this weekend if you're not playing it if
you don't mind somehow if you know but
if you're not is it this weekend
no it's next weekend it's next weekend
Holi not that interest perfect if I were
change it